all right well joining me now for
reaction is Dan Crenshaw he's a
Republican running for Congress in a
border district in Texas Texas second
district he's also a decorated former
Navy SEAL we've also have a Leonor an
immigration attorney here to debate
gentlemen thank you both for being here
so commander I'll start with you you
know you've got a situation here where
the the president sees an eminent
national security threat based on the
status of what's happening on our border
Congress will not deliver on a border
wall in the funding that he wants so he
says we're sending the troops now we
know there are limitations and what they
can do at the border but is this an
important step and will it help stem the
time it absolutely is and he's making
good on his promise to the American
people that's what he ran on he ran on a
border wall and it looks like that
border wall for now temporarily will
have to be enforced by national guard
and we have a long history of this in
Texas and frankly we've been footing the
bill we're on the front lines we realize
this is a national security issue and we
spend our own money to actually put
Department of Public Safety troops on
the ground to help enforce the help
assist law enforcement we also put
national guardsmen on the ground
regularly to help with counterdrug
operations this is nothing new to us
it's important to us and frankly it's
time for the federal government to help
out Allen so here the Dan Crenshaw just
mentioned the Department of Public
Safety in Texas based on their statistic
from 2011 to 2012 over two hundred and
forty five thousand criminal illegals
have been arrested in Texas alone 1000
over one thousand homicides 77,000
arrests assault arrests 78,000 drug
arrests seven thousand sexual assault
arrest these are illegal aliens in Texas
alone arrests between 2011 and 2018 yet
based on some of the commentary I've
seen you say there isn't a crisis at our
border would you not acknowledge that we
do not at the federal level have our
hands around the border and now is the
time to address it well I think there
are ways to address the issue of the
immigration crisis and actually the
border wall and actually an individual
wall and a human wall is not the way to
best address the issue and to best sort
of show that this is a man-made crisis
as why now it's been 12 months into this
administration and now all of a sudden
after this last fall of Congress which
there was sort of a dock a deal for a
wall that he sort of ran away from that
we now wanted to
boy people to the troops and it sounds
like to me that Texas has it under
control for the state of Texas and
that's really what the concern is right
now a little bit about federalism and
what the National Guard is in place to
do so if states have the drop to put
these individuals in place to do what
they do at the national level then why
should the federal government sort of
step in why not now is immigration not a
federal issue mean Texas may have
stepped up to do its part but ultimately
this is something it affects all of us
and what the federal government should
be doing you say why now I ask why not
now if we haven't stemmed the tide and
Congress hasn't delivered right because
there's no way to put humans in the way
of the danger of standing at the border
one for the National Guard officers
because when you think about National
Guard officers they're part of
communities they're firemen and police
officers and teachers that are part of
communities that keep them striving keep
them safe so you're removing people from
from communities and putting them at the
border for a threat that doesn't exist
for what reason
right remember there's no caravan so
sort of show me the threat that doesn't
exist dan I'll go to you as well i
rattled off those statistics 245,000
criminal illegal since 2011 to 2018
arrested in Texas alone we're talking
homicides assaults drugs sexual assault
over 10,000 for weapons he says you know
Ellen says no threat here humans can't
do it if not humans and not a wall how
do we ever get our hands around this and
is it not a national security issue
we've got an invasion problem here it's
a national he did he did he did say one
thing that was absolutely correct which
is that we waited too long we should
have done this before we should have
done this a long time ago and frankly it
has been done before the left is is
losing their minds about this but it was
done by Obama in 2010 and by Bush in
2006 so he's right that we have waited
too long he's also right that it's a
dangerous border and so that you can't
simultaneously say that the threat
doesn't exist while also saying it's a
dangerous border and too dangerous for
our national guard our national guard is
going to be doing down there is be the
eyes and ears for a law enforcement that
is the role they're going to play and
it's a very useful role to role we need
in Texas Department of Public Safety
here in Texas knows very well that we
don't have the manpower demand every
single inch of this border so this is
extremely helpful and we welcome the
help and it's and it is a federalist
this is an international border to say
that the states have the resources to do
it is wrong it's not true and Texans are
on the front lines and we're trying
we're tired of footing the bill Allen as
Dan as Dan has said I mean the the if if
you don't have people there then you've
got to have a wall now if we don't if
you don't want to send the people there
Allen if you don't believe that the
National Guard serves a proper function
there which could be a legitimate
argument if you're if that's your true
concern wouldn't you then say well now
it's time to time for a border wall we
have I would say do something actually
is the access absolutely you would have
to do something and some of the ways to
sort of stem this problem without
spitting the wasted money is to sort of
look at technology because if people are
really just there to sort of look and
observe that's something we do at
iPhones that's something we do with
cameras that's something that we can do
with tripwires there's no need to have a
human person there to sort of look and
see what's going on so that argument
sort of falls weak there and sort of the
concerns of what could happen the danger
at the border fires iPhones and
tripwires are not a wall are not a
beautiful 30 foot border wall that is an
actual obstacle that interdict people
trying to come across your border it's
very so the National Guard if you're
understanding the rules of what the
National Guard can do at a port of entry
and with regards and sort of if you sort
of hear the plan that is it doesn't
exist as the governor of Oregon sort of
said that these individuals are not
allowed to detain people or be involved
as regular police officers so therefore
they're only there to sort of be in the
background which he said we need them to
be the eyes and the ears for enforcement
that obstacle without oversight is not
effective so if you've got eyes and ears
on an obstacle exactly both layers
necessary and and that was in isn't
wrong that we also need electronic
surveillance to to bolster this effort I
mean it's a combination of both okay
with any operation and to say this
operation wasn't planned or that there's
no planning there's no talk about of
course of course there is okay this is
this is a very simple military operation
we want to stop people from crossing a
border so right so you need you need
electronic surveillance you need people
on the ground and then you need law
enforcement in conjunction with that in
order to be able to arrest and detain
well secretary basically just said in
your own skip that they were coming up
with the plan that would be enforcement
that would sort of comply with law so
therefore there can't be a plan because
if there was a plan then we'd already
have seen that
the Pentagon's gonna presenter and these
things can at least we can all agree
that we need a border wall right Dan no
this is a temporary solution and great
solution because Congress cannot get out
of their own way appreciate both of your
time to stand that's why I'm running for
Congress
you got it